Now, as you've probably heard over and
over and
over again,
there's no reward without risk.
And we often want to consider
multiple stocks together and
evaluate their risk versus return.
So, one way we can do that is
plot them on a scatter plot
where each dot here
represents one stock.
So risk goes along this axis.
Return is along this axis.
So for instance,
this stock here has higher risk,
but about the same return as this stock.
And then for comparison,
this stock here has shown, historically
about the same risk as this stock,
but it's got a much higher return.
Now we can build the portfolio
by combining multiple assets,
like the various stocks I've got
plotted here and waiting each asset
by a particular wait that represents
it's allocation within the portfolio.
So each stock has a wait and
when combined altogether
we end up with a portfolio that has
properties of each of the stocks.
It's typically got a risk
somewhere in the middle there and
a return somewhere in the middle